on the streets of Rio de Janeiro it's
less crowded than usual but not as empty
as local officials would like after
presidential ball senado again made an
appeal to Brazilians not to punish the
economy by staying at home The Cure
cannot be worse than the disease as
covert 19 continues to spread Brazilians
are torn between listening to their
president or everyone else
defiant governors and mayor's have
restricted all non-essential activities
including church services thoughts
inaros battle against social isolation
has isolated him politically as never
before except among his hardcore
supporters like street vendor Edson
sampaio I support the president we need
to open up the streets again as fast as
possible I would be able to last much
longer calls for the president's removal
are escalating one of seven petitions
for his impeachment has just been
presented to Congress with more than a
million signatures and a Supreme Court
judge has asked the prosecutor general
to investigate the President on charges
of crimes against public health also
narrow has been delaying the
distribution of Congress's emergency aid
package for millions of poor
self-employed Brazilians hoping that
will bring them back onto the streets
nevertheless removing both so narrow now
is not widely popular because it could
create greater instability says public
policy expert Pablo or tell ellos in a
sense there is a parallel government
where you had of the Congress the
Supreme Court and the governor's are
handling the crimes do you think that
also narrow can survive this crisis it
depends what happens if if we have too
many deaths which will probably occur
but we don't know what what what rate
then boazlin always probably is in big
trouble because he will lose most of his
supporters or significant portly support
but if the governor's managed to handle
the crisis in the death that that's are
not that high
maybe he got away with it it's a risky
bet for the leader of Latin America's
largest economy whose popularity suffers
with every new burial caused by
coronavirus lucia newman al jazeera